not reinforcement learning and uh and
from this point on everyone has to obey
rules
yeah that's right that's right that's
this is our chance yeah we can
we can solve this very say
oh it's funny
so people ask questions by posting them
in the chat
well they can yeah oh that's right so
yeah that's right the people
who aren't panelists have to do that so
i guess
well it's two more minutes according to
the berkeley rules
um but we actually we have oh no we've
got participants who are
are coming in um
so
so anybody out there
post some crazy question to start a
discussion going if anybody feels like
it
participants out there um
[Music]
by the way just to clarify i'm not
officially on the panel i'm just now
right but we can see yeah questions like
this is my
uh time off so yeah we can because
they're absolutely asking questions i
think we have a lot of
expensive phrases there we can't
well that's right uh two or four
stochastic adaptive control from
1980s is reinforcement learning
[Laughter]
i think some elements of it in
reinforcement learning
i think it's it's different from
adaptive control although these days a
lot
we're doing adaptive control and calling
it reinforcement learning yeah i know
that's one of the reason i thought of
that
but if you like look at the minimum
variance adapter control
you know you're just you're trying to
solve
a really boring optimal control
objective and
um all you care about is the output
you're doing it purely online different
sort of at least an
adaptive control that i remember people
estimate the parameters
of the system and then controlled it
based on that but
the thing about reinforcement learning
is that you don't need to know what
uh how many states that are in the
system and you know that that's a huge
deal well that's what they
say but the theory is different than
than the dream right
um and the other way around is like in
adaptive control people did have the
direct methods and actually
like the same random search uh show that
appearance in the 80s or something like
that
i forgot the name but like there are
these things are going around
at the same time i think uh there's a
lot of new stuff that that's happening
and then
uh a lot of them faces some computation
right so that's gonna be
the perspective that's a little bit
different right like
if you were doing adaptive control at a
time maybe
you would even write things with
continuous time
for that matter right like yeah maybe
get
the noise uh i mean like that that's the
uh main body of uh that happen in
elective control
also much of the work if i remember was
asymptotic
oh yeah and and stuff for sure of course
i mean uh
it's like after some planes went down
everyone was jumping on
let's prevent that yeah
and we we ran away from common at the
time yeah
it almost seems like you know the the
the thread that were pursued by
adaptive control and maybe more
specifically stochastic adaptive control
and reinforcement learning they're
kind of merging because the focus there
was more on continuous state space and
particularly linear system models
whereas linear reinforcement lending was
focused on tabular
uh models and then you increasingly see
people now trying to
go not necessarily
you don't agree absolutely not i think
that
reinforcement started with this
functional approximation
sorry maybe maybe uh what you're
thinking about
is that people realize that one point
that all that they are doing is dynamic
programming they were very happy with
the tubular thing because finally they
were able to prove theorems
uh but it shouldn't be confused uh with
what the field was about the field was
about this you know
checkers like let's solve checkers it
was very clear
that you will not be able to build a
table for that
right yeah i don't know i i i agree with
that
with a linear function approximation is
from at least 1988
uh t5 85 okay yeah else sideman
schweitzer actually bam on did it
already
uh with splines and then there is this
paper that i like to
popularize uh which basically goes
through all the adp
algorithms without any analysis but it
just proposes all of them
uh-huh uh yeah
it's it's an operational paper i think
or something schweitzer
what yeah really like in that paper you
find ai
you approximate uh i don't know like
there are no queue functions okay so no
action very effective
but but without like besides that it's
pretty much everything
there seems to be some question oh
there's a question here okay
all right um but uh
you know we'll come back to history
that's fine uh majority
let me read this i have a question later
sean's talk
a major issue of the standard
formulation
is that the gain should be large in the
beginning but slow at the end
newton-raphson gets rid of this problem
by converting the dynamics to a linear
one
it's making everything easier the
downside is we
get a second-order method that's for
sure whether it was about the
alternative doing
a form of gain adjustment media grading
dissent
i mean i love that i mean yes yes yes
i mean so i gave one example where i
wanted
high gain far away and logan nearby
i could have easily cooked things up so
it was different but
there should be a way of adaptive
uh gain selection in a dynamic way
especially since it's a bit of
robustness you know you can get away
with
um you know with some
some you know some sloppiness
so um and i know people try to work on
this i mean warren powell had an entire
nsf grant on adaptive gain selection for
for reinforcement learning i don't know
where that went um
but no it's a good point because um
we definitely want to get away we want
we went to some sort of compromise you
know being able to
fully linearize the dynamics like with
this newly epson flow
is is beautiful but but it's way as you
say it's
it'll be way too complex most of the
time we need some sort of compromise
so what we say i was thinking
oh something similar to mit rule and
adaptive control
and you have i2 wheel which killed the
pilot
no but but we're not going to we're not
going to put it on an airplane so it's
okay
oh can anybody comment on that i'm like
how the mit will oh i'd have to review
that but
uh anybody else have a comment about
yeah like wherever the pr people of mit
when
someone was able to call this through
the mit
oh man um i have a i have a broad
question if there are no other questions
so so i guess i mean much of the success
of reinforcement learning
is based on offline training massive
amounts of data and things like that
whereas the original theory was for
uh online i mean you're learning and
you're controlling at the same time and
ben van roy talks about artificial
general intelligence i mean humans don't
learn with you know you're given
millions and millions of miles of
driving data and then you start learning
to drive
that's not how we do things so so
since chaba is in deep mind what do you
think
java what is the state of online
reinforcement learning and are there
successes
my light break guys
i don't know uh should i answer this
question
well i i think that the field broadens
and it's okay
like and and this happened way back uh
i i remember uh
it was some icmm like
over 20 years ago where uh i think demi
and ernest
and and also shy man they were like
talking to me about that
hey like do you know what is batch thing
like we should all do
that's the important thing because uh
no one allows us to run our algorithms
online because they're unsafe
uh but they are willing to give us data
so why don't we look at that
i think that like okay that was the best
thing and then
i think that people found it too hard at
the time
to like no one was really excited about
at the time about
running things in simulators uh
and uh so there was uh no
uh fantasy of that like you would just
use a lot of compute i guess there was
not a lot of compute
and then you would like train something
in a simulator and deploy
like that it was not existent so the
only reason people
started to look at the simulation model
is because
it was just easier to analyze so there
is the parallel simulation model that
i don't know um shem maybe was
involved and sat in there and uh i don't
i would need to think who who exactly
was the culprit
uh but the theory started this this
simulation
optimization thing because it's just
easy to analyze
but then of course the experimentalist
people didn't care
and they just run things anyways
and it seems to work and i would say
that i'm
really excited about all this work
and the prospects of using uh
learning together with optimization in
an offline scenario in a clever way uh
as a way of you know preparing your
uh your arguments like it's a way of
programming
uh like this big verse like seems that
it means not much but i think it's a
completely new way of thinking about
uh um
how you can program robots for example
or how you solve
complicated problems rather than
thinking long and hard about uh
how to come up with a compressed
representation of a system
why don't you have the computer to part
of the chart
right like in the past we were really
like uh you guys did a lot of work i
guess
about this um reduced order
representation or like using diffusions
and then being clever about what to do
things
but it's great uh
maybe that knowledge is going to be
useful one day i hope it will
um but but but at the same time people
overlooked the possibility of just using
computers
more on the optimization side and i
think that there is a good reason for
that because compute part was just not
that that would
make viable but these days it's it's
totally that so
this opens up new possibilities
yeah okay yeah and people have been
really disappointed doing alexa maybe
alex could could make a comment that
he's here
yeah more people that's right on a
little bit of the
offline side as well and this simulation
based optimization
is actually a terminology that i'm
stealing from them
oh god it's too bad that alex is there
any way to
allow alex to uh you're talking for me
oh
oh you can't oh good good good okay cool
because it would be good to get your
input on this yeah
um did you hear what i was just
listening
okay yeah yeah but basically this was an
attack on the controls community that uh
instead yeah we use the computing power
and forget about all this uh model
reduction and then synthesizer control
or whatever
um let the computers do the work
but it's uh it's sort of like but it's
i mean i'm when i'm with you the chatter
for sure
yeah yeah i don't know something
a lot i don't see any contradictions
different type of problem problems what
we considered
so what what you wanted me to
actually i i'm curious about the uh
like you've been in operations research
and in operations research
people talk about simulation based
optimization since for a long time
and and do you like okay so how did it
started like i'm really curious about
that like why do people look at
simulation of
because when i first met this thing it
was like totally weird
it was like either i want to do this
online or maybe
i want to do it based on a batch of data
but the fact that i built a simulator
first
and then i use that to come up with a
good good controller or whatnot is well
it is that a little bit strange
first of all simulation optimization is
the different communities which
understand it quite differently
okay and uh
no for example it was long ago they
started in
global organization which didn't lead
anywhere i think
also there was a lot of talk about that
things so
what i was talking is somewhat very
specific
this was a which revolutionized
the stochastic what i would call
stochastic problem and
this is a way how to solve optimization
problem
involving say we expected the
expectations
because it's going back to basic monte
carlo ideas
so again this is the way
how this is in that area
is that we can sample from something
we even don't need to observe this model
exactly but the whole
point we can sample from that and then
the whole theory says how to use it
efficiently
in order to solve problem because from
the deterministic point of view this
problem are interactable
it's very easy to show from the
beginning and this was long way
because this stockholder the stochastic
problem going backward
to origins of linear programming if you
may know
danzig formulated that and
so linear programming they were lucky
and it worked not immediately it took
something 40 years before it started
to be practical maybe even more
right but this idea of these
scenarios that they use didn't work
or it wasn't just but then
this because just to compute expected
value or in multivariate case
is not possible accurately
in principle but this is all these ideas
this
theory and algorithms which were
developed really went in different
direction
i don't know if the if a control
community can learn something that we
certainly would like to learn from
control communities
um i mean this electric car companies
use a lot of simulation based
optimization so so they drive the car
and then get the data
and then they have a model in their
offices i mean they visited a few of
them and and
they they use that to refine the
controllers
by controllers they mean trajectory
planners and and then they go and drive
the car again get more data and do the
same thing but
but it's really built on having a very
good simulator
in the office because because i mean
like java mentioned earlier we can't you
can't drive a car and
you can't learn to drive a car on the
road you have to already know some
amount of driving can try to make it
more efficient but it can't be crashing
the car right so
kind of interesting so they go drive
drive the car get data about other
drivers
uh you know what their behavior looks
like and then they use a bunch of
collection of models for how aggressive
the driver behavior is
you see there's a different ways how you
can look at it
when i talked about that was something
very specific
way of doing optimization because
simulation is very
big area now everything is simulated
so because of that even simulation
optimization different people understand
it very
differently
but maybe i don't know this if i look
mdp models market decision processes
and again it has a very long history
with a lot of theoretical developments
but the applications of that are
somewhat
limited
except that now it seems that they are
everywhere
yeah this yeah like uh
whatever you see in reinforcement
learning it's the same thing it's like
there is an mdp underneath okay maybe
the state is not observable and then you
build some observer state representation
or whatnot but
uh you run a value approximate value
iteration or
approximate uh policy iteration some
version of it there are zillions of
versions of it
and there are really exciting problems
that you can solve with this
simulation-based optimization technology
that uh we were not able to get
even close to solving just because
you're like you have to give credit to
the neural network folks right
yeah they work with high dimensional
observations
and like somehow like that doesn't
bother the algorithms that much
it's you see what you mean this soul
right
you run some computer and my telephone
can translate from one language to
another this is science fiction ten
years ago
yeah and this question about that
guarantee of solving that you don't care
about it right
i i think that people could care or
would care
but of course worst case not nothing is
going to work
and then the delicate job is to figure
out
uh what are the operating conditions
uh what are the unknowns what are the
nouns like how do you describe the
problem such that
you can uh granted something meaningful
uh and that's really challenging because
uh
well the fir for the first place we're
using the simulators because we're not
able to do that
we don't have very good characterization
of what type of problems we want to
solve
we can write a simulators in that sense
we know the problem that we want to
solve
but the properties that make a solver
possible for the type of problems we
want to solve
are unknown right and so then that's
that's the detective work
that should need to happen if you really
want to
grant it but people still want to have
robust target terms right so they don't
want an algorithm that
if you try it on the next problem it's
going to break
let me ask simple question do you care
about this all this if it is uh
guarantees and all that do you care
about i'm a theory so like my heart
breaks if we don't have the grantees uh
do but the question is whether the
people
who are going to run these experiments
or the simulation-based optimization
whether they care about the graphics
i think the answer is that they don't
perceive
care about the grantees they care about
whether the algorithm is going to be
perfect right no one really likes
to use more compute than what they need
to use
and currently everyone feels that we are
already stretching the limits
of what we can do with the compute
and we can solve amazing problems or
like okay so solve like
i'm going to use this word solve in the
layman they which means that like it
looks good right like
it's happening
it was supposed to do it it seems that
like if you're exposing the robot to all
these tasks
then it passes the task it's it's great
it feels great
um and so there's a thing but like
no one is really happy about when you're
running your argutime and then
you know like the preference goes up and
then it collapses and then it goes up
and causes the next run
a different run-down seed it does
something crazy
and it's not reliable and maybe after
doing it for a
billion random seats eventually does
something it's not that bad but
but people want to have more robust
arguments and so as a territorian
uh i think our input uh could be that
we we can just give them uh
more of us target terms and and one way
of doing that is
through theoretical analysis by thinking
long and hard about what makes what
doesn't make sense
our job is to prune away the branches
that grow out
uh which go nowhere um
i don't know i see that at the moment i
see around
all my students your point of view is
win
right everybody's machine learning now
and then i don't know what will happen
and we i cannot say that what i show we
have this
spectacular successes of that
the progress is slow right and
if we want to give certain type of
guarantees the
complexity analysis very pessimistic in
principle
so we resolve certain type of problems
but nothing spectacular like that
i don't know what will happen maybe it
will in the future it will be
something i don't know sean that is a
question
yeah that's good yeah but wait it's
actually more for you shabba
so sorry to drag you in kicking and
screaming
but there's a amir has a follow-up
question for you
can you see that uh is is it for me uh
maybe everyone following shiva's point
that uh
maybe we can rely more on computation
power of modern computers i'd like to
know what you think about approaches
common in the
community that try to learn algorithms
themselves maybe you can learn
learning to learn it's etcetera i'm
thinking of using neural tutoring
machines
yeah you can take it too far for sure i
mean must do this
do you think and it may be concerned
that hubris for the theory community no
i don't think that it should be should
be
so sensitive to this uh so maybe we can
use some of
formal verification to provide guarantee
and to learn methods
yeah i'm not sure about the form of
verification but i think that uh
taking it to the next level uh and
thinking about learning to learn and
whatnot if you have more compute maybe
you can solve harder problems
uh or maybe uh if it appears that you're
making the problem harder but it's
actually not
that much harder so i don't think that
this
should be outside of the scope of what
we in the theory community are thinking
about
uh absolutely not i think we should
embrace the possibility of using
computers
for doing uh the work uh that we
used to do uh that's great uh
we still want to know like what are the
limits of this and like how should you
do this in a sense above a
uh are there you know like uh
you you see talks and uh like for
example shikon was talking about hey
people like
if you use double q learning at least
please talk about the
the learning the step size or aditya's
talk
he says that oh if you're looking at q
learning
and and you're plotting things uh don't
plot
like whether q learning converges that
doesn't make any sense plot whether the
span norm converges right
uh things like that like these are
valuable contributions
uh and can change how people are
interpreting results right so you're
plotting for example but the q learning
converged
and you think that oh i'm tuning the
hyper parameters to make it converts
faster but like that makes
and it's going to come very slowly
anyways uh in that metric but that
metric is not
important and so it's a very valuable
contribution uh
so like even small things like that can
help a lot
i think i don't know i think
i have a heart stop and i have to leave
good seeing you everybody so
yeah yeah thanks a lot sweetheart it's
great to see you
so um you know one
way to maybe think about this there's a
gap between
you know rl and our algorithms and
theory and simulation based design and
that that's physics right so when we
simulate i mean
you know we essentially are simulating
the physics right
usually it's problems of that kind and i
think how to
sort of incorporate that in a meaningful
way
that is sort of missing and you know
there is
this question about formal verification
that was raised
or not necessarily question but as a as
a
as a goal i think unless we i mean
it's not to say that we do have model
based rl uh algorithms right but the
models are
very simplistic and the problem that we
want to apply this to
the models are really complicated and so
if you want guarantees i mean shurikan
was talking about autonomous driving i
don't know if rl can solve the
autonomous driving problem but there are
many other
simpler robotics problems that one could
try to solve
so incorporating the physics somehow i
think that is
uh you have a good point and i think
aral is missing out
uh like some part like the mainstream
model i should say
it's gonna have to miss out on this uh
quite a bit but here i don't necessarily
think about that you should start
you should go back and then start to
write the activations again and feed the
model parameters and whatnot but
but in control you have so many other
ideas that people
were pushing that are go uh that are
going
unused in in reinforcement learning for
example this loop shaping right so that
you can
have a like loops in loops and and
gradually transform control problems
into other control problems that are
easier to solve and since of course
can directly use physics right like that
you can use inside
or decentralization and whatnot like
use physics in ways which do not
directly look as using physics but it
does actually
use the the structure of the problem
i don't know what shown what do you
think oh and it definitely i mean it's
just
i mean the way in which airflow flight
control works
is this beautiful hierarchical structure
and as you say
you know the the ailerons have their own
little control loops so they look very
linear and simple
and that's all local and then and
because it's so simple it makes the
global control problem simpler you
have a simple linear system and then
there's a big loop around that
and then get away with these just really
uh really naive
control laws because of the because of
the of the architecture
um yeah and what's so sad though is it's
like they've developed that so
beautifully
for flight control and then and then in
power systems it's pretty cool
all the droop on the generators
is one local loop and semi-local
i mean this is a cool that's the trouble
every field seems to have
their own hierarchical control strategy
to solve their problem
um and one problem with rls is trying to
solve everything
um you know it's uh maybe that's that's
also such things but by the way that
this view of that
decentralized and whatnot can be also
easily
because maybe you know computers just
like are powerful enough so that you
don't have to do this anymore
yeah well it's the intuition though i
mean it's so
nice for there to be a control of an
engineer in the
in the control of the power system or in
the
you know or at delta airlines who really
has intuition
about why the plane is working so well
you know and they see some oscillation
at some frequency they have some
intuition about why
it's so nice to have that you know it's
it's reassuring all these really
really critical applications so
somehow you can get stuck with this
intuition though right like
think about the game of goal right oh
tell me yeah
you play the game of goal at
an extremely high level compared to the
layman
so they have a lot of intuition and very
good people
pride write on the intuition
into rules that may cause your goal
and eventually what means is a learning
system
and search system right
yeah well it's kind of elusive sometimes
these intuitions are good for capturing
some basic stuff but like do they go all
the way
probably and then when computers are
becoming
powerful enough maybe we should just
like bend their knees and then say that
okay okay oh that's so funny
your turn john doyle are you here
john or just uh
the fact is that we'd have i mean it's a
john
i mean maybe he stopped now but he used
to in every meeting like this would talk
about
optimization and fragility instead of
this sort of
necessary evil that as soon as you
optimize you're fragile
[Laughter]
oh right yeah yeah and so
optimization area encompasses robustness
by definition
yeah if it can if you can that's not
easy yeah
i think what that is uh optimizing it is
is not easy right yeah yeah
so chaba what you said actually kind of
raises the question which is uh
is it just a matter of just throwing
more and more compute power
and you know better hardware and all
that right
and we can solve rl can solve every
problem or do you think there's
you know as we want to go to more and
more
i mean you know uh there was some
illusion earlier to uh
artificial general intelligence so you
as you want these systems to
to to do more complicated things and
display some level high level reasoning
so do you think
more compute power is going to be enough
or something more is needed
i think that in the framework or
otherwise
yeah yeah i think i don't think that we
do have the answer to all this and i
just
need to scale up compute and then
suddenly you're gonna have a robot that
hurts me the beer like that thing
uh is is a little bit beyond i think or
capable it is yeah this is the century
yeah
yeah but um but i think that people are
still overestimated
underestimating uh and i'm probably also
underestimating uh what computers can do
[Music]
really mind blocking
yeah they're so different and foreign
that like we have a hard time accepting
that
i know differently than us and there's a
new question here
well fine important
all right
[Laughter]
that's great yeah talking about the
bitter lesson right
um
his conclusion is is kind of uh well he
calls it a bitter lesson because
people have a hard time accepting
that sheer compute can
[Music]
do things that
seemed really hard like particularly
solving particle
problem instances that seem really hard
and of course
yeah and of course so when you ask me
about like whether computers can
translate
a lot of negative results what they can
do right
but it's always a question whether this
next instance that you care about
like is that a hard instance for this
type of algorithm or not
so i have a follow-up question on that
so uh
this is not good like uh so
so currently we almost have not not we
but maybe deepmind and googles of the
world they all
they have access to data center scale
computing
so what problems what are their problems
that are even
hard for data center scale computing and
now we're asking for a
i don't know even you know even larger
scale computing we cannot solve those
problems because we even data center
scale computing is not enough
i mean it seems like we have enough
compute power right i mean we have gone
beyond uh super computing and all that
the the sad state is that we only know
if we try
and then we may fail
that's what's going on right like people
are trying
people are failing and when they stop
failing then you hear in the news
yeah yeah that's that's right and
that is i wish that there was some way
of
measuring problem complexity or like you
know like how do we estimate whether
it's time to uh to solve some problem
with
whatever solution techniques we have
uh well usually you can start counting
like measuring things and then
you have an estimate that okay with this
much compute i can do it
not in these problems so that's the sad
thing that and
that goes back to that we don't have a
good way of describing the problems we
can solve
and we have we don't have a good way of
assessing
the complexity of the problems that we
want to solve in terms of those measures
that we don't even know no
but like this is something interesting
that
i think theory could contribute
right like know before you start to like
have an estimate of whether
you can finish it's really hard because
we're talking about individual instances
and yeah exactly
of course you're gonna need general
characteristics of this instance
some of the instances are going to be
super easy
in a hard class and some of them are
going to be super hard
depending on which algorithm you choose
right
it's a messy a messy thing but it's it's
not
completely impenetrable hopefully
i mean it's a territory you should
stop being then you can make a
difference in a word
oh boy so i guess i mean oh the official
schedules will be run now to
get the free margaritas right um
yeah i i think the schedule says we go
off to
um get i'll wait so
oh yes so let's answer this question so
panelists
what do you think of metal learning and
how is this going to help rl
and i think i'm not qualified um
who are you qualified aren't you i don't
know much about it maybe java you can
[Laughter]
begin
we already touched upon this right so it
was kind of like
going in the same direction and my
answer is that it's it's
it's great uh meta learning is
uh is really fascinating uh
and theory is uh
[Music]
i i'm i'm working on some some problems
related to meta learning
and it's really nice and fascinating
it's wide open
i encourage everyone to
yeah so i think uh i mean this is
uh going to be an ex it is an exciting
area but it's going to be very
uh exciting given in the future but i
um i think that
we have to find the right framework in
which to think about it i don't think we
have found it yet and that is true for
many prop many problems in rl not just
meta learning
you know going beyond the core rl right
and
so uh maybe in the future we'll we'll
figure that out
interior you do two things you define
problems and then you solve
problems right so and then you get back
and forth
uh right and uh
for metal learning it's uh yeah like
there is this challenge i can talk about
the people that is submitted and will be
rejected soon
uh based on interviews it seems
uh i'm still very happy with the paper
it talks about meta learning
and uh it talks about this phenomenon
that uh like i think a lot of people
were wondering about there or
are wondering about that in the worst
case of course mental learning is not
going to happen your tasks are
completely
independent the future that is not
almost structured to be shared and like
uh and uh so you can either go for a
best case analysis when you're making
some strong assumptions
and then uh if the assumptions hard then
you should add
meta learning algorithm somehow can
uncover structure latent practice what
not
and then can do better on future tasks
uh that it was
able to do before there are very few
papers uh that are doing this but there
are some
some really nice new ones that uh just
came out
so that's like the best case analysis
and then the worst case analysis a lot
of people were doing worst case analysis
in the past
those results are so disappointing
because in the worst case you can't
do much you're not going to
lose much compared to the private
learner and
but then it happens that uh
that is something in between so
sometimes you can characterize how hard
a metal learning problem is
depending on the structure of the
instance and
i think that there is a lot of
possibility for that and that that's the
paper that we wrote that
goes there tries to do this in a too
simple setting for the taste of the
reviewer so the paper is going to be
rejected
but i think it's it's it's good like we
can do more of this
and it's really interesting uh so there
the question is okay you have
family problems uh and the problem
itself
defines uh how you want to exploit the
structure of the individual instances
right so
that that the problem definition itself
should dictate
uh whether meta learning should have
whether the task
have some simulator or whatnot so people
talk about transfer for example in mdps
right so when you have a bunch of mdps
and then random sampling then that's
your new task and then
you want to know whether you're going to
transfer well universe case you're not
going to transfer anything
uh in the best case a lot of things are
shared maybe all the problems are the
same
then you're going to transfer everything
and there are cases in between
and what you want to build is an ergo
term that figures out
whether there is much to be transferred
so that's kind of like the
the formula version of uh
this method learning let's say in the
framework of uh
reinforcement learning but of course
meta learning
may not need to stop there right like
that that
is just the the standard first idea
of that uh tasks are coming at random
and you want to play from valentine's
text that's just one model like you can
have so many different models
so i think it's very nice
so uh
this question nobody has read so far so
maybe i will raise it which is
uh machine learning
broadly and not excluding rl so
in particular vision let's say right so
they are faced with the question of
how to go from 99 to acute accuracy to
beyond right i mean 99
accuracy is not good enough for
many applications right uh so rl has not
faced such a question yet
so how are right in the sense that okay
something you know you design an
algorithm and
we you know that the fact that it will
work 99 of the time is not going to be
good enough
how are how is that going to be answered
how do we
you know yeah so i mean how do we
think about that i mean you know are you
talking about
um
[Music]
like issues related to deployment like
for example
safety and yeah yeah yeah yeah right
i think that you go with the good old
engineering practices so whenever we
don't have an answer we just say
engineers are going to solve that
[Laughter]
but rl rl is going to take over the
world at some point so yeah we will be
responsible for everything
but so if you want to know whether you
are like your system is safe to deploy
what do you do like ah well you expose
it to a
bunch of standardized tests until uh
everyone's tired right right right but
uh
you know there's the uh in complicated
problems you will always keep on finding
corner cases it's never going to end
yeah yeah autonomous vehicles seem so
interactable
yeah it's great right like uh a lot of
times and people people grow into uh
i think uh it's not like that like we
shouldn't we shouldn't
uh believe that we will ever have
absolute truths right like absolute
truths maybe it doesn't even exist there
well no no no it doesn't
that is true but you know a model would
be for example you know we
uh at least for most people prior to
well maybe i shouldn't say that so
so you know uh most people you know feel
fairly comfortable
you know climbing onto a plane and
flying somewhere else right
until the last couple of years when you
know very small fraction of equality
started to have second thoughts
uh so i mean that that is not
uh there is no 100 guarantee that that
something will not go wrong
but there is very high assurance that
the plane is not going to fall out of
the sky
you should like believe system that
makes you believe
that that is a very high assurance and
uh
like because like of the history of the
whole thing uh
people got convinced that that we have
sufficient proof that it works and it
seems to work and i don't
see why that wouldn't happen if you have
this complicated
household robot that was you know
trained with some arrogant terms and
like no one really knows how it
works but it's been around and
it never hurt anyone and the beer
and uh you expose it to various tasks
and like you're poking in different ways
and it doesn't fail
and then eventually you get convinced
that it's safe
uh yeah it's it's pretty serious though
like the the the type of tires that you
would expose this thing
to uh but it like this is what i call
the normal engineering practice i think
the normal engineering practice can
still be applied
um i i don't think that there is much
uh i mean like the systems that we
ordered the bed
are incredibly complex right like
it's mind blocking how many parts a
plane is going to
have so once i walk into the office of a
guy who is working on verification
and he had this big
poster that showed the bullying i don't
know whichever plane it was
and like you could like use a magnifying
glass and still see details and then
it's like different scales and that's
probably not even
scratching the surface of like how big
the systems are
and okay big systems are here
somehow we managed to uh
to keep them safe i don't think that um
like just the fact that uh there is a
learning argument there
uh missing your network is going to stop
anyone
uh believing that like in these big
systems the verification algorithms
occasionally do find bugs right um
does it mean that the verification is
only as good as the model
right that's the either they they found
all the bugs does it mean that
it's absolutely safe no but like up to
a degree of satisfaction that that fear
is that like
there are two diligence i think the
importance is due to the chance
you shouldn't be lazy if you want to
deploy something like that like being
lazy
it's not something that's yeah
that was the problem with boeing you
know just yeah it's
like yeah just uh yeah well you think
about
the virus situation right now just
incredible and and the uk is going to be
our guinea pigs
they're going to be the final uh if they
don't die then we get to have them next
year
that was the news today the uk's
volunteer to
to testimonials for us in the us
um but uh yeah it is incredible amount
of
yeah it's like money that goes into
verification
yeah do you know it's safe yeah
and we won't no until everyone gets a
shot yeah
yeah that's right
that's fun yeah
but i i still bet that this hierarchical
point of view in engineering is going to
stay you know
that you're going to just because it's
easier to
you can you know contest sub-systems and
get more confidence that way also also
oh well this i cannot answer okay this
is this is for you
what do you think about alpha fall 2
whoa uh so so let's let's do the next
version of
yeah i guess yeah i don't know i wanted
to make it true but
it's not a good show okay
i don't know uh actually
evolutionary arguments uh
that that is that is at least one very
nice book
that is about the theory of evolutionary
arguments and i really like that so i i
wanted to say
who's that oh i should like sanity it's
a springer
book and and it's written by
mathematicians and
it's all full of markov chain and
releases you will love it
yeah i will post what this book is
uh because i forgot the title i read it
uh years ago
and and it's like it asked these
questions
uh okay like you guys claimed that
evolutionary arguments of everything but
okay let's keep it simple and uh easy
can it solve commercial optimization
problems for which we
know that polynomial time solutions
exist oh yeah
don't do that then don't think
but they show that it can
but all the all the problems that they
looked at they're able to show okay it's
not
you know optimal uh polynomial orders or
whatnot
but it's okay right if you have a
general tool
that you can throw at problems you don't
have to think
that's that's yeah yeah i guess like we
are going
going back to this these days where
people were really excited about
evolutionary arguments
uh i got the solution about them because
of the uh
the two big claims that people were
making that's not good
but but but they may have at all right
so it's
it's not an old or nothing yeah
so all right anyways
um yeah
so yeah i'm told we're out of tequila so
we don't have to worry about
gather town there's no new margaritas
today but friday
friday
all right i should go yeah i guess i
guess the meeting should be adjourned at
this point
um one of us is very tired
um but uh yeah well i mean boy
thank you participants thank you
speakers what a blast
i love i love this community it's
awesome
all right thank you bye bye for now yeah
thank you
you